I believe that this nation
should commit itself
to landing a man on the moon
and returning him safely
to the earth.
After thousands of years
gazing up in the heavens
and dreaming of this day,
a man is about to set foot
on the moon.
Across the world,
people wait with bated breath.
Ladies and gentleman,
this is a live signal.
There he is!
The shock across the nation
at this event
is just indescribable.
♪ Music playing ♪
The Soviet cosmonaut
has become the first
to set foot on the moon.
♪
We thought it was about
being first.
Turns out the stakes
are much bigger than that.
Get back to work.
We're still in this thing!
Change of plans, gentleman.
There is water on the moon.
This race
will be ours to fight for...
[ENGINE REVS]
...and to win.
And we are not stopping there.
Moon lab.
We need to accelerate the base.
You're going to be
an astronaut candidate.
No, I'm going to be
an astronaut.
We're going to Mars. Saturn.
The stars. The galaxy.
Drifting right. Watch it!
Eagle, this is Houston,
do you copy?
♪
This is not the end of the race!
We must keep our eyes
to the future.
Three... Two...
♪
[RADIO STATIC]